the eh-2-zed of isms transhumanism most
of us would consider the end of the
human race as a catastrophe there are
some however who would not only rejoice
at it but want to hasten the day it
arrives transhumanists look forward to a
future in which Homo sapiens is
superseded by a better smarter fitter
model humanity 2.0 humans are in dire
need of improvement any species that
causes huge damage to our environment
can't feed itself even though it has
enough food and fight some countless
wars costing millions of lives must
surely benefit from an intelligence
upgrade our life spans are short our
final years usually characterized by
diminishing health and vitality often
accompanied by a drop-off in cognitive
capacity one in three people born in
2015 are expected to get dementia is
this really the best we can hope for
transhumanists think not ageing could be
stopped and even reverse enhancements
could dramatically raise our IQs and
make us stronger and fitter we might
even be able to leave our fragile bodies
behind and upload ourselves to computers
living forever in virtual worlds
improving humanity through science and
technology could radically change us
such a new beginning would in effect be
the end of humanity as we know it many
transhumanists see this as not only
desirable but inevitable the scientist
and futurist Ray Kurzweil believes we
are approaching what he calls a
singularity the point at which computers
become smart enough to learn for
themselves after which they will rapidly
become smarter and smarter the future
belongs to artificial intelligence the
only way for Humanity to survive is to
embrace it and become wholly or
partially artificial ourselves the
thought of being replaced by a new form
of humanity is bound to be unsettling
but transhumanists think we will be
wrong to lament the end of humanity as
we know it when what replaces us would
be so much better it would be like
wishing children never grew up or that
Homo erectus
never evolved into Homo sapiens if the
transhumanists are right weed could be
one of the last generations of humans to
roam the planet thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon